forget the election the battle for the
supreme court is one of the most
important in america
it won't just affect people's lives for
a few years
but for generations on the 18th of
september 2020
ruth bader ginsburg died and her spot on
the supreme court of the united states
became vacant this was a big shock to
politics in america
as a replacement needed to be appointed
and the person who got to nominate a
replacement
was president donald trump before she
died
ruth bader ginsburg asked for her
position to be filled
after the election but sticking to that
wish
would mean donald trump missing out on
one of the most influential
and lasting decisions a president can
make
as the highest court in the land it has
the final say on any laws which are
brought into question
it interprets the constitution which are
the core principles on which
america is based and more crucially
its nine justices serve for life so once
you're on the supreme court
you'll stay on it until you die holding
a seat
is one of the most powerful positions in
the country
political leanings can massively impact
the decision
someone makes as it stands the court is
split with
five conservative judges and three
liberal with one spot left to fill
and the appointment of a new member is
an opportunity to cement those beliefs
into laws for years to come
so who was ruth bader ginsburg and what
did she stand for
it was exhilarating to help bring down
the barriers
that in justice brennan's words put
women
less on a pedestal than in a cage
she was a liberal icon a heroine to the
american left
after overcoming entrenched sexism
she was a fierce advocate for women's
rights
and delivered landmark laws on abortion
same-sex
marriage immigration and health care
she fought against loosening of gun laws
viewing the second amendment as a relic
of the past
so how about president trump's nominee
today it is my honor to nominate
one of our nation's most brilliant and
gifted legal minds
to the supreme court amy coney barrett
is a devout catholic
and a conservative she's a judge and has
been a professor of law at notre dame
law school
she would also be the youngest supreme
court justice
and based on average life expectancy of
u.s women
would probably serve around 30 years
in short it's a massive chance for
donald trump to leave a mark
well past his term as president
and you think we should take the
president at his word
when he says his nominee will do the
right thing and overturn the affordable
care act
i can't really speak to what the
president has said on twitter
i'm not here on a mission to destroy the
affordable care act
but amy coney barrett's past judgments
show an almost uniformly conservative
voting record
in cases touching on abortion gun rights
discrimination and immigration
and there are many who believe her
appointment could be a threat
to democratic values president trump is
attempting to roll back
americans rights for decades to come
but a common defense is not to assume
how new judges will vote on the supreme
court
as members don't always vote the way
their history suggests
now for our part i i would never presume
how judge amy coney barrett
would rule on the supreme court for
example republican president dwight
eisenhower appointed earl warren to the
supreme court in 1953.
warren went on to preside over one of
the most liberal courts in u.s
history championing the racial
desegregation of schools
and upholding the civil rights act which
outlawed discrimination on the grounds
of race
color sex and religion eisenhower is
said to have called it
the biggest damn full mistake he ever
made
so how does the process work well once a
candidate is nominated they're
interviewed by the judiciary committee
this involves the nominee being asked
many
many
questions we've been grappling as a
nation with a lot of these
issues would you like to respond to that
at all before i go ahead
i'd like you just to clarify that point
sort of like a job interview
then the senate votes either appointing
or rejecting
the nominee this is an important choice
because it's an opportunity to
turn the political dial to the left or
the right and the appointment of amy
coney barrett would
stack the court 6'3 to the right
and it wouldn't be possible to redress
the balance until another spot became
free